I'm joined today by Deborah SATs who's
professor of philosophy at Stanford
University she's the author of numerous
articles and several books including why
some things should not be for sale the
moral limits of markets this is a super
interesting talk topic to me Deborah and
we've talked for example about how even
a believer in so-called capitalism
generally should be able to recognize
that there are some areas of life that
are not best left to the free market for
example I think health care is under
that umbrella health care in an economic
sense does not have elastic demand
there's effectively zero demand for most
health services by most people until
they all of a sudden have a condition or
disease that requires those services and
then all of a sudden they really need
access to those services so I've made
that case economically you deal more
with the sort of morality and philosophy
of it so talk to us about how we can
sort of think about the moral limits of
markets generally so so first of all I
think some of the economic arguments
those selves have moral dimension so you
know in thinking about inefficiency
efficiency is partly a normative idea
you know why do we care about efficiency
why does it matter
but a lot of the reason markets are
inefficient is when they have third
party effects that's a case also of
health care
you are bad health can affect me like
you're not being vaccinated can affect
me but we need a moral theory to tell us
which third party effects matter or not
that said there are some markets which
even if they could be efficient in the
delivery of goods and services we still
think it's inappropriate to market those
kinds of goods the most obvious one is
slavery nobody i think should object to
slavery because it's an inefficient
system with the idea that if it was
efficient it would be acceptable right
we think that it's simply
you know these are the human beings are
not the kinds of things that should be
bought and sold and there are other
items human hearts might be another one
we don't think people should be able to
sell their hearts even if it's the case
that two people would want to do to make
an exchange
same thing with slavery even if people
wanted to sell themselves into slavery
we don't think that the state ought to
enforce those kinds of contracts and I
think that's another important point
about markets a lot of people forget
that markets are institutions that
depend on enforcement mechanisms and in
that way they're really the concern of
everybody they're not just bilateral
deals between two single individuals so
there's an analysis to be made which you
sort of started to do with some of these
which relates to the the sort of way in
which the participants in the market
would be affected so slavery as an
example might be at the societal level
mathematically efficient in some way but
we would say that morally it would be
wrong to buy and sell people and us that
shouldn't be allowed there's also the
site of externalities right so when we
talk about the most efficient
organization of fossil fuel of
procurement and refinement and
distribution which might be the most
efficient way to get fuel from the
harvester through the refiner to the
end-user but there's all sorts of
negative externalities that we should
consider when we think about whether it
should be left to operate in the free
market can you talk a little bit about
negative externalities in this context
so economists of course think a lot
about negative externalities or positive
externalities so there are a lot of
market trades we're not just you know
people making the trade or affected but
third parties the obvious example would
be you and I make a arrangement but as
an effect of our trade pollution is
produced and people who were never
parties to that trade now bearing the
cost of pollution so that's a third part
effect in fact in life and in
interdependent societies third party
effects are everywhere you know if you
buy a shirt from the gap that I don't
like the color of that is a third party
effect on me so we need to pick out
which kinds of third party effects are
the ones we think are important enough
to regulate or in some cases even to
prevent a market from forming and that
again is where moral theory has to come
in because it has to tell us which are
the significant third party effects
something that might look like it's just
a two-party deal can have very
significant third party effects in my
book I give a case of if you think about
child labor as a as a market which it is
in many parts of the world
it obviously has direct effects on the
participants and we think there are lots
of reasons that children are not made
better off by being able to participate
in these markets but there's also what's
called a pecuniary externality there's
an effect on other prices if you have a
widespread child labor market you also
affect the prices of adult labor and by
making adult labor therefore cheaper
because it's now in competition you
increase the labor supply it means that
families they don't want to send their
children to work are going to be under
more compulsion to do so because the
adult wages aren't that high and that's
why Oh so just to get close this thought
in some cases closing off a market makes
other options available for people that
might not have been available had the
market existed so you can think about
wage minimum wage laws as something like
this they prevent some trades that would
be beneficial to the parties themselves
from forming there are probably some
people who
wanna work who will not be able to find
work once a minimum wage is in place on
the other hand there's a third party
effect of not having minimum wage laws
which is that the wages for everybody
are affected most of our audience is in
the United States and most of the
audience that is not in the United
States is in primarily what we would
call sort of Western democracies so I'd
be interested in hearing from you I
mentioned and on the program I've often
mentioned education as well as
healthcare as two areas of life that I
believe should be outside of the
so-called free market can you talk about
for the bulk of our audience what other
areas you believe should be outside of
that model as well so I'm gonna push
back a little bit the way you formulated
this because it's not a sharp inside or
outside
yeah and should be clear I mean I guess
I should also further clarify which is
that I don't even see it as free-market
or the opposite of free-market but
really I'm talking about regulation
right taking sort of real life into
consideration when we decide how free of
a market it should be right so yeah I
don't like the phrase free market in the
sense that I think all markets are
social inventions that are you know
depend on there being background
property rights enforcement mechanisms
social norms of trust and so all markets
are shot through with regulation it's
just a dream that there are these
completely unregulated markets now some
markets are less regulated than other
markets sure we can talk about degrees
of regulation it's a I think an
interesting question to ask what Goods
should never be in the market no matter
how much you could regulate them and you
know again the canonical example would
be slavery we think you know even a very
regulated slave market there's something
intrinsically objectionable about
treating human beings as if there
the kind of objects that should be for
sale some people think you know human
organs are another example unless I
would draw less a hard line on that but
I do think that there are lots of
reasons to not have if you allow some
kind of trading there's many many
reasons not to have a traditional market
with many buyers and many sellers for
different kinds of things so take an
organ mark you know organs if you were
ever going to try to incentivize people
to give up their organs the last thing
you would want would be a system which
distributed organs according to ability
to pay you know we think that human
kidneys ought to be distributed
according to need and so some one
society we only have one society in the
world where organ markets are legal at
the moment and that's around is a
monopsony where the government buys the
organs from people and distributes them
on the basis of need so that's a it's
not inside a market but it's not out
totally outside either there are other
forms of exchange my colleague at
Stanford al Roth has designed kind of
barter markets in organs where if I need
a kidney and the people who love me who
are willing to donate one are not
compatible and you need a kidney but you
have people who are not compatible we
can engage in a trade if people are
compatible with my people so that's not
a market exactly I mean there's no money
changing hands but it's using aspects of
a market right in order to more
efficiently distribute the kinds of
organs there are and some of these
matching you know barter markets with
organs now they've gone up to almost a
hundred people where they you know have
long chains of trade and that allows an
efficient dispersal of the kind of
organs they have so you know
I think the inside-outside I don't you
know or something is in a market or not
I think we just have to recognize that
you know mark not all markets are the
same and some kinds of markets raise
ethical problems that other markets
don't so organ markets raise lots of
ethical questions that an apple market
doesn't raise labor markets raise
problems that an apple market doesn't
raise you mentioned education and health
care
those raise ethical problems that other
markets don't raise for example in
education we're not just you know I'm
trying to trade goods we're trying to
produce citizens and so we have a lot to
to care about the effects of our you
know distributive arrangements on the
production of human citizens in an apple
market we're not trying to produce you
know citizen apples we're just trying to
get apples that are edible
so some markets we know tend to have
feedback mechanisms on the things that
are being exchanged and labor markets is
probably the best example of that you
know Adam Smith worried a lot about
workers who spend their whole lives as
appendages to machines not become being
good citizens right and so he argued
that we have to have state the state
playing an important role in education
we don't have to worry about Apple
markets producing you know you know
mindless sheep but we do have to worry
about what how what our education system
does or what our labor system does
because we're you know there's a
feedback loop between us in the market
Deborah the book is fascinating it's
called why some things should not be for
sale the moral limits of markets we are
recommending in and linking to it for
our audience we've been speaking with
the book's author Deborah sat's who
teaches philosophy at Stanford
University thank you so much for talking
to me about this and I'd love to have
you back and go go deeper in some of
these specific areas
well thank you it's great to talk to you